it's an endless source of frustration
for me that somehow neither side of the
political Spectrum ever seems to
contemplate the possibility that some
women might enjoy looking after their
own children I mean there's the the
stay-at-home mum tax is the marginal tax
on single earner families is brutal I
just think that's mad the data show
again and again and again that children
are better most happiest and most
well-adjusted except in you know outlier
situations of family chaos or
impoverishment children flourish best
either in the care of their own mother
or father or of another extended family
member why is it beyond the wit of man
or why is it beyond the wit of
politician I suppose I should say to
look at policies which could support
more children growing up in that
environment I don't know but somehow
Somehow Here we still are it doesn't
seem to matter how often people pointed
out it just never never gets through